welcome back to new rock stars this is
our inside marvel q and a
bonus segment from the falcon the winter
soldier episode one
mtni had just watched this we've already
done our inside marvel reaction
uh after show uh and uh with the
breakdown
by the time you're watching this on
youtube at least uh will have already
been out on the channel but there's a
lot of easter eggs uh
specifically in the ending part of that
show in the end credits
it's like there's as many easter eggs
and all that graffiti as there was in
the episode that came before it
but mt and i are going to ask what's
really going on with sam
in this episode specifically is sam
being set up by his government
is he being set up to fail are they
quietly
and politely though you could argue not
really that polite
trying to take them out and get their
own guy in there
because there's some evidence in this
episode that uh that could be the case
empty how you doing man welcome mt to
the show hey everybody what's going on
it's good to be back to take some
questions about marvel um and about uh
specifically falcon and the winter
soldier but yeah
it's very sketchy what's going on with
sam i'm very
not thrilled about it no one is i don't
know why i said that because everyone's
pretty pissed about it
um but yes there's some stuff like some
sketchy stuff going on this
behind the scenes like you i know you
mentioned in the um
in the in our previous episode about you
know the military possibly setting sam
up and i thought that was really
interesting
yeah so we're going to talk more about
that and uh but you know we're on stereo
right now
thank you for everyone listening to us
on stereo stereo is the
live podcasting app where you can do
live shows and submit your voicemails to
react with hosts in real
time uh you just record little
voicemails here and then the hosts play
it and they react to it and it's kind of
cool it's like a live podcast it's
awesome
uh you can uh download this if you're
watching this later at stereo dot com
slash new rockstars
and for all of our stereo listeners
right now uh we want to know what you
guys thought of this falcon winter
soldier episode what were your burning
questions that came out of this
uh stuff maybe that we didn't address in
addressing inside marvel
um you know other burning questions
other weird things you noticed
and if you have some thoughts on whether
or not sam might be being set up
um do you think torres is in on it do
you think he's just um
he's in the blind as well uh what do you
think this whole batroc mission was at
the beginning of the episode
uh we want to hear from you so go ahead
and drop those voicemails in there we'll
be addressing them in this q a
throughout this episode
um so empty but while we wait for some
questions to come in
i want to know from you uh what do you
think the whole point of
you know bacharach's mission of
kidnapping this uh versant
guy was was it just like an opening
mission that they do in action movies
and we aren't meant to really question
the specifics of it
or was there some greater purpose to bat
rock taking this guy
and sam being the guy sent on this
mission that is an excellent question
and the
answer is i don't particularly know at
this point but it is a very
interesting thing going on because
batroc seemed to really
want this target he was really really
obsessed with getting this man
to the fact that he was just jumping
from helicopter to helicopter and the
most insane and fun um
air sequence i feel like in the mcu
personally i was i was a big fan of that
sequence
um but i definitely do think that this
um
batroc um thing that they're setting up
is going to be significant down the road
we just don't know exactly um in what
way
let's go ahead and reach toward it
though because here's my thinking i'm
wondering if batroc didn't really give a
[ __ ] about
vassan that bad truck was being paid off
just because
the last time we saw a bad truck in the
mcu captain america the winter soldier
uh
he captured with his like pirate
militants the
ship the lemurian star and uh sidwell
was on this ship
and cap and uh natasha were deployed to
rescue it
you know uh captain phillips style and
when uh that movie's story unfolded you
find out that nick fury actually
set up all of that he paid bachrock
to do that he wanted that ship he wanted
intel from it uh
that guy's got spies everywhere you know
and that's kind of his old mo and that's
part of the reason why it was so hard to
know who to trust in that movie
the first you know the first act of that
movie were like wait is nick fury gonna
be the villain of this story
is he going to set up cap to fail you
know and then as things go on
you realize his whole spy network was
his own own undoing
uh and i think so that's the rule for
batrock so far in the mcu he's not just
a general baddie he is someone who's
really good at helping governments
pull tricks on their own avengers just
to kind of test to see their loyalty and
to help them get like raw information
that they wouldn't be able to get from
these noble noble avengers
so you know that's where how did batroc
get out of imprisonment you know
these people zemo batroc they were
locked up
how do they you know uh it's so the fact
that that truck's back just tells me
like
is the government trying to pull some
[ __ ] again is sam
the fact that like you know he's so
defensive against torrey is messing with
this drone
red wing because he says uh ops keeps
screwing with it so it gets glitchy
like there's enough here to make it seem
like sam should be afraid by
what his military allies uh allies that
roadie kind of signaled to him hey you
can't trust allies these days
i think sam's being set up to fall out
of the sky
you know rudy style and who knows that
better than rhodey
yeah i mean yeah with uh his experience
with riley and all that stuff he's uh
he's definitely got some uh
well i'm talking about roadie when he
you know boom looking forward
he's falling oh oh yeah yeah rhodey
definitely he took off
he took a tumble in a civil war uh
unfortunately because uh because of
visions
but no for sure like uh like that that
definitely that
military um type deal with his pack like
that's really interesting for me because
like
why are they messing with it like why
does it constantly keep getting messed
up
and uh yeah with with um batroc i mean
what you said was perfectly like
rational and possible because bat truck
could be working for somebody else
another actor to um you know to hurt sam
to get sam
out of the picture so that he is no
longer a candidate for the shield
possibly so
that's a good line of thinking i like
that i mean if this is a true a total
conspiracy as i said
and look i i'm gonna fully say right now
i've barked up wrong trees plenty of
times before
me too me too i'm the captain of barking
up rock trees trust me
yeah so this you know there's plenty of
signs here which just could be
the writers being like no the reason
this is unexplained is because it's not
worth paying attention
to totally totally possible we just know
that by the end of this episode sam's
own government
doesn't care about him and wants him to
give up that shield
that same dude that same government
official is like oh thank you mr wilson
you did the right thing handing this in
to us
and then it's like the cops being like
thank you for turning in this heroine
and then as soon as you turn your back
there back there
up that heroine like sons of [ __ ]
what
this belongs in a museum heroine belongs
in a museum
the fact that they bring in white
russell cap john walker cap at the end
it's like
it's clear that they're trying to do
this sneaky thing of bringing their own
people that they can control better to
be the avengers
and sam is one of these people i think
they're not fully gotten over the
mistrust from
uh from the fact they wouldn't sign
their sokovia accords
and we saw the sokovia accords in the
exhibit it's kind of like well
there's still an effect and we know
bucky got a pardon but on the condition
of meeting with his therapist every week
what was sam's condition does he gonna
have to do these military gigs as a
condition of his pardon
but i i kind of want to know is if there
is a big bad if there is like um
someone who's orchestrating this
conspiracy from the top uh
uh that government official he's not
even given a name or a
title in the credits it just says
government official i think it was
zach off-screen zach said he looks like
ben bernanke
the chairman a former friend sheriff and
so it's like it's so funny that the guy
who controls the
financial markets of this country is one
in charge of this field
but no i think there's a good argument
to be made that um you know thaddeus
ross could be part of this
uh oh yeah now we know he's in black
widow
maybe he is the government official who
unlocked batroc who unlocks zemo
and he hates you know half of the
avengers and he's like let's get our own
guys in there
and you know there was an interesting
line there he's like on behalf of our
secretary of defense on behalf of our
president
uh i'd like to introduce you to captain
america yes there used to be
uh president matthew ellis and that was
around the iron man 3 era yeah that was
like almost a decade ago in the mcu
though
yeah we would have a new president even
after the blip we'd have a new play we'd
have a
president during the blip yeah what if
the new president of the mcu
was secretary of state former secretary
of state
thaddeus ross because it's a historic
pathway to the presidency secretary of
state
to pray he would be a prominent national
figure he would be the strong military
leader who would uh make promises to run
earth uh throughout the blip and would
be kind of threatened by half the
avengers coming back
like that just be a kind of fun like oh
yeah you would be a presidential
candidate
absolutely so he could be uh you know
president thunderbolt or something like
that and mcu just has elected not to
mention that yet
and as soon as we see that we're gonna
be like holy [ __ ] he did this
he's he's sam that would be crazy
if ross was president i i mean
personally i just think that ross
loves having like direct authority a lot
and so like
i do i think that he loves being in in
charge of like
soldiers and like you know and having
that direct power
and like you know obviously being the
president is being the
commander-in-chief so like that's the
most power you can get
but like you know there's also politics
and all that stuff and i feel like
um thaddeus ross is more of just like
all right man let's just
let's do this let's get the hulk we're
like let's just like you know do
like make our thunderbolts and all that
stuff but i do think that they are
setting up the thunderbolts here
potentially potentially
um with uh like you said with bad truck
if bucky got pardoned
like who gives that pardon it's assumed
a presidential pardon
that's where that came from so that must
have come from the white house as well
like i i don't think anyone else says
absolutely i mean you can get
judges to issue pardons you can get
people in the justice department issue
pardons but the absolute
uh pardon comes from the white house
that's the one where you can't like
undo it you can't like say oh this
doesn't count actually
so uh again um there's there's a lot
here i just think it
it makes sense for so many people in
this world to not
want uh to have to work with sam it
doesn't make sense for us we know
he's a good guy we want sam to be our
hero but like just like in a post blip
world
uh you have evolved past needing certain
of these avengers and now they're back
and the last time you talked to them
they were fugitives like
it's a difficult conversation to have
yeah for sure for sure
let's take a question would be great
yeah here we go
i think they wanted sam to go into
libyan airspace to have the libyans
shoot him down
so they didn't have anything to do with
it oh
interesting that's interesting uh yeah i
do like that idea i would say
why not start in libya maybe if that's
the case
um but i think either way they needed
this to be an aerial battle so they
could have plausible deniability when
sam's
uh you know um exo wings
failed and glitched and they were able
to say oh that old stark tech must have
just been glitchy now that tony stark is
in here to fix it
oops sorry we all mourn sam wilson a
hero and then
he gets a creepy little exhibit put in
the smithsonian too and they're like
we loved him but we're secretly happy
he's bad
and like yeah and going into libyan
airspace would cause a big
international incident and like you know
it would just be a huge
issue and like they were just actively
trying to avoid that so i don't think
that they wanted him to actually enter
libya i think that
at the very least if there is a
conspiracy like eric said
um just take care of it at the border
well before they hit the border anyway
yeah um but i think that is an
interesting idea yeah
uh the whole idea with tunisian versus
libyan airspace is uh is significant
um or maybe it's not but it seems like
it's kind of important
right um not just because like we're
we're fairly friendly with libya but uh
or very friendly with tunisia but not
with libya
uh and bacharach i mean my first
instinct is maybe bacharach is being
hired by the libyan government to terror
uh
to kidnap a pilot but why this pilot
like does he have intel was he part of
some program
that like you know some hostile actors
trying to be like
let's get that pilot because he's gonna
be an important wedge issue so that like
the government does not want that guy to
get in
enemy hands for whatever reason um
but um yeah let's take another question
long time listener um big time fan
uh question do you think sam wilson's
sister is a flag smasher or the us
agent it just seems like there's too
much there
one of them has to be i need to know
your theories jess clemens
we love hearing from you oh i miss you
so much
jess so uh yes
jess asks a fun question here so let's
talk about sam's sister sarah
um she has some you know she's going
through a lot she's raising these two
kids essentially by herself
um there was that interesting line where
she told the loan officer empties she
was a widow what did you make of that mt
i mean you know i i think that she
probably had a boo
that is just gone now and um i don't
know
if he passed away during the blip or pre
blip but like
you know he uh she's definitely holding
things down on her own
and so you know i i i don't think that
she's this flag smasher
um like in particular because you know
she's just
you know she's just trying to take care
of her family um
but i i definitely think that
she will probably just be around just to
help um
like you know give background to sam's
past and
and um you know probably to help him
convince him to like take the shield
back because that's uh
something that he's struggling with in
the entire series yeah i think uh
yeah i so far i haven't really seen any
evidence that she's a flag smasher i but
i do think there's a deeper story there
and i'm wondering if like the reason
she's a widow
uh is i i don't think she was a widow
before the blip
right um those those kids are pretty
young
i'm wondering i mean the world is
chaotic during the blip uh i
you know we assumed that there was going
to be like roving bands of of looters
and stuff like that
so i wonder if her husband uh died
during the blip like maybe he was like a
firefighter a paramedic or a first
responder in some kind of way
and like he was just trying to keep the
established order
and uh things went crazy and maybe she
feels a little resentment towards sam
for not being there during those five
years to
help keep everything safe i mean at the
time there's no way she could blame sam
for that because he's yeah
you know he's gone and she's heartbroken
over losing her brother
but then when he comes back maybe she
like a lot of people feel like well if
it was that easy why didn't you guys do
it sooner why did it take five years
you know um i mean the avengers have a
completely fair and honest answer for
that they needed scott lang to
poop back out of that i mean blame the
rat blame that rat in the san francisco
georgia for taking so long to free scott
lang from the quantum realm
really like come on man just chilling in
the van just
yeah we have to remember the whole world
within the mcu did not watch avengers
end game
uh and even the people in our world who
watched avengers end game are still a
little unclear on everything that
happened
i mean apparently watched the avengers
end game because they were like hey no
thanos cheated
so like i don't know how they got that
intel but they were apparently they're
watching end game just kidding um
so yeah i think uh mike but jessica asks
a good question because i want to know
who is and who is not aligned with the
flag smashers in this like yeah
is right now tori's got his butt kicked
by a flag smash so i assume he's not one
of them
um but like uh or maybe he's not one of
them yet maybe he's about to get
inducted into the flag smashers but if
we assume all the flag smashers are the
product of like
some kind of enhancement testing whether
that's like carl malus the power broker
as we were kind of
talking about in inside marvel um and we
did get that easter egg
in the uh in the credits sequence of the
power brokers watching
um i'm wondering if there's this whole
alternate history within
the world that we haven't seen it's been
erased by you know government read
action and everything but
there was that other easter egg that we
spotted a little bit later the um
the that test subject form and then carl
lumley's face was there
um so like they might be doing the
isaiah bradley uh story and maybe he was
part of a secret initiative
that was there to enhance people and it
didn't really work out
yeah then the five smashers kind of
evolved out of that uh they're like the
gen
3 test subjects and then they're like
you know at the one time
our people were not cruelly weaponized
was when there was no government to
weaponize us we were in the blip we were
free finally
and wasn't the world's kind of weirdly
better there were whales in the hudson
uh
let's let's live in this world
right there's more efficiency for sam's
sister to
you know fish if she wants to in the
pier
um and i think that's the thing with
sarah is like she
there's too much you know coincidence
the world is too small if also an
avengers sister
is you know his history was he was just
an air force
pilot and he's part of this special
program uh with riley
uh so for her to also be someone who
was connected to flag smashers at i'm
not sure i'm not sure yeah
i would uh i would yeah i would think
you hit the nail on the head here i
think that she's just there
just to be a you know just a regular
person and i think there's value in just
like the regular people of the mcu and i
think that's really great
about these um disney plus series like
with wanda vision like we got to
literally hang out with just regular
people for a bit and just to see
how these these superheroes and like
their world
affects regular people so like i really
like um
regular people like vision white vision
agatha harkness you know just regular
joe schmoes
you know monica rambo who's got some
weird physiology
yeah i can relate i can write but you
know isn't that great i weirdly want a
vision
made me relate with these weirdos in a
way that the mcu hadn't before like i
connected with them emotionally which i
thought was so impressive oh and before
mt and i continue
we are happy to announce the new design
for the latest obsession number three
shirt from new rockstars and our merch
partners at epic hero
it is this amazing looking falcon in the
winter soldier inspired design
especially from those glorious
incredits so filled with easter eggs
just like this shirt
it's pure anarchy or in this case
anarchy assembled
now as always these are limited edition
collectibles so
once they sell out back in the blue
dungeon they go you gotta get your hands
on these fast
you can get them at
newrockstarsmerch.com and when you do
you'll get the added option to write in
a custom shout out that will appear on
screen during our inside marvel
falcon the winter soldier after shows
let's take another question
my question is is why did sam give the
shield
back to the government i mean captain
specifically gave it to him
and told him it was his so i really
don't understand why he gave it back
yeah the answer sam gave us or gave to
rody was that he felt like it wasn't his
and he they kind of took that exact line
from end game but i love how they gave
that line a new meaning just by taking
away alan silvestri's music
and putting in a henry jackman scored
henry jackman just gives this kind of
dark undertone to it where it's like
no this is meant to be a doubtful line
an uncertain line of burden
and uh so i think from sam's point of
view
uh i'm not in his head but i would
imagine like he feels really
uncomfortable anyone carrying that
shield
after after steve rogers it should be
buried with steve rogers and essentially
since we don't have a body to bury right
now the closest thing they have is this
you know metaphorical tomb of the
smithsonian exhibit um
so that's why he's so outraged at the
end he's like indiana jones that belongs
in a museum you know i don't think he
thinks no one should harness this power
right now or
and i think there's also something that
they alluded to um
so far it's just in small doses he feels
an inherent
uh discomfort with wearing the stars and
stripes
um and i think he mentioned this line
tutorials like
look when something gets better for one
people it gets worse for others
and when he sees what his sister's going
through i think that kind of reinforces
this whole idea of legacy it's like he
he thinks that you know he should be
able to just put these things aside and
he can go back and just look at them and
he can respect
the fact that they're just stationary
but he's now realizing oh that's not how
the world works the world loves to
loot and take and steal the spoils of
war and reuse and repurpose stuff for
their own
goals and if you want a legacy you can't
just set it in stone you got to fight
for it
you got to keep working to keep it in
the right hands
and that's the struggle um but what do
you think i've been talking too long
sorry mt
no no you're fantastic no that was
really good stuff i really liked it that
was uh really
profound i really touched me on the
inside
no uh but no i think that like this is
such a huge like
this shield has been around since world
war ii and so like
in captain america is this like huge
like almost like god
type figure that has just come up like
he's back in like what 2012 he came back
he's like hey i'm back from world war
ii and like you know so like he's this
god-type figure so when he's gone
you know and we have this shield that's
been around since like the the 1940s or
whatever it's just like all right
i'm not cap and like uh and like
everybody would probably
feel really upset if i was just like i'm
cat now so i'm gonna put this in a
museum
because this is now like a an american
world artifact because
i feel like that makes sense for sam at
this point
like he's just like i would rather just
you know let cap's legacy be cap's
legacy and i know cap wants me to have
it but like
i don't think he really understands what
it means to not be
cap and to take his shoes because like
it's a lot it's a big huge
responsibility so i don't blame
sam for giving up the shield i blame
those
mother freakers who tricked him
and gave the shield to the freaking
matthew morrison cap
uh it's wyatt wrestle but i just love
him
he looks like him he looks just like
matthew morrison and people have been
making the joke that he looks like uh
the old man from up which is spot on
literally
perfect i love all of you guys for that
uh i love that
i definitely do think that this uh sam
and from my point of view anyway
he just probably just didn't take it
because it was just really big shoes to
fill and it's like
you know i would rather just you know
leave that
for history um i agreed yeah i think
that's a good point mt and i think the
the design of that shield is a target
like it's a bullseye target
and i think sam sees that as a burden
that he's carrying around as soon as
cap walks around with that shield he's
literally got a target on his back the
way he wears it
and i don't think sam is eager to carry
that target around he's got enough of a
target as an avenger
and i think he likes uh the gear he's
got
uh he just doesn't want anyone else to
have it um and that's a hard thing to do
with legacy it's kind of like
you know my my dad was in the navy for
31 years and the
the they retired at his whole retirement
change command he uh
he had this line where he said there's
like uh ten
two letter words that he tries to keep
uh
in mind for all this decision he says if
it is to be it is up to me
and i that's always stuck i love that i
love that so much and i think that's
what uh sam is realizing now it's like
great fine i'll do it myself
that's such a good i'm that's literally
gonna stay in my head forever now that's
so good
keep that in mind uh i mean obviously
delegate share responsibility find
your team also important but like at the
end of the day
sometimes you just gotta get your hands
dirty and do it itself to get to get it
done
um let's take another question why do
you think sam
was tiptoeing around the avengers income
with the banker dude i didn't like the
banker dude he was very sketchy
and gross but still i don't know that
was weird
yeah uh my theory that i kind of talked
about in the breakdown
um which will be coming out uh for
serious listeners later today if you're
watching this on youtube has already
come out is
that uh it's kind of a nebulous question
i think sam was like this isn't about
my past finances it's like you know
give my sister to the loan she deserves
realistically that is a question of
how sam and uh cap and natasha and wanda
envision
were getting by for those two years if
they didn't have a connection to stark
at their government
saw them as fugitives so my thinking is
that
uh maybe wakanda t'challa was hooking
him up and
sam didn't want to expose that right now
that he had you know
they had this alliance his friendship
with the king of wakanda
and by you know exposing that to the
loan officer it would be like
well then why don't you just go back to
your rich friends and the most you know
the richest and
most valuable and superior nation on
earth and uh and then now maybe
something's going on wakanda where sam's
like well i can't go back to wakanda
right now
because obviously they're going to move
on from the fact that they had to
challah they're not going to
try to recast t'challa after chadwick so
i think there's some answers that need
to be
more questions that need to be answered
there but i don't know maybe they just
were homeless and were real resourceful
honestly i like that answer i i that's
the that's a pretty good answer i'm
gonna take that answer
um as my own answer because
honestly t'challa would hook him up he
would hook him up because he just
wouldn't
he wouldn't be like all right all right
you guys suffer like no this dude is
like loaded he's one of the most loaded
men in the world
i think probably the most bloated man
yeah we did a big question on that like
who's the richest uh
and i think or because he has all the
riches of asgard
might be um richer but t'challa is right
up there because just
i think the value of vibranium is like
10 000 an ounce or something like that
it's insane so imagine they have a
mountain manga that's tough
he's a rich dude yeah he's got a whole
lot of that uh
that good rock sound
good rock that's an ac dc lyric yeah
so throughout the first episode they
were telling falcon and the winter
soldier story separately
so they have to connect them at some
point how do you think they're gonna do
it
oh that's a good question that's a good
question
what's your theory um let me think about
this
i think that
it's probably zemo because zemo is on um
hit uh bucky's list of people to make
amends with or whatever
and do his whole thing so like you know
and zemo as we've seen from previous
trailers
has some type of connection with um
carly morgenthau
um because he was i think so yeah he was
uh seen talking to
her and like a group of like youngish
people inside
oh yeah and so um yeah
so maybe like she has known zemo in the
past and she was radicalized by zemo
and you know hooked up with you know
this power broker this is all just
theories by the way
um got her powers and then like started
uh smashing because it's like hey
zebo taught me how to say like
like flags and stuff um so yeah
but yeah yeah yeah who i think that um
zemo will probably be that link but who
knows yeah i think so and i think
um bucky's list will be what leads to
zemo because we know zemo's on that list
um he was like the third or fourth name
down and i think that will lead him to
zemo and zemo's going to give him an
interesting pitch
for what goes next now it looks like a
bucky and falcon are fighting the flag
smashers so i don't think they're gonna
like join
up with them at first or ever um
but yeah i think that's gonna making
amends
you know i just love how this making a
men's list making amends could mean like
apologizing to people but it also just
needs killing people's still
like people are arrested or cancelled or
whatever it is
so it's just like wait uh this name oh
do i need to kill them or apologize
oh wow i think at the very least he
needs to tell them hey listen i know you
can do me as a winner soldier but
i'm just bucky now you know just yeah
just don't don't hit me up on facebook
as the winter soldier because that's not
me anymore
um yeah i also find it interesting that
um
uh like in the trailer you see bucky and
sam
kind of hanging out at sam's home at his
uh at this louisiana home
and i think like like and they also have
the shield
so do they fight uh white russell's
character to get that shield back does
is jessica right and that the shield he
has is just a prop that's not the real
one
uh but if so would they have to go back
to the smithsonian to steal it
like something's gonna happen with that
shield's gonna get
you know fumbled and uh repossessed
and a lot of different people are gonna
have it in this show um maybe they feel
like white russell doesn't deserve it so
they steal it
and then from there forward he uses a
prop but they're like we need to
protect this shield like a baby and then
it's like an adorable like
the shield is their baby and then
they're like the shield won't stop
crying at night well it's your turn
if you're trying to feed him pucky and
he's like oh all right you're trying to
rock the shield all right i'm going to
sleep
[Laughter]
but uh yeah no like uh that is a good
point with because the shield is
at um like you said at uh sarah's place
um with with sam and all them i think
that shot is probably somewhere towards
the end of the series
where um where sam does get the shield
back and like his nephews are like
oh snap my uncle's captain america now
um which is uh i i definitely feel like
that's the case there
um but yeah i think that shield might
actually be a fake shield that um
uh russell's character has um because
why
i know what like when captain america is
doing his captaining no one sees it
he does it off somewhere else and then
like he's like all right now i'm back so
like
that shield that he has doesn't have to
be real it just has to look like
captain america's shield whereas and
then they can just store it somewhere
else so like i think that's a good point
i think that's really good
yeah let's take another question do you
guys
think that it could be having to do with
technology or something like there was a
real focus on him recording things and
just i don't know maybe there's some
kind of mind control
oh mind control mind control um
yeah i think well uh in the way that
technology was fairly important to one
division i think you know the
the ins and outs of the new tech is kind
of uh
at this point a genre staple for every
marvel film
uh whether it's mysterios holographic
tech barf you know
whether it's the technology of uh the
quantum tunnel to go
commit the time heist but uh yeah i
think in this case
um that whole ar symbol of the
uh of the flag smashers is is going to
be important in some way
i think the sam's technology glitching i
don't think we're going to get some big
like you know villain bond style or like
you know
uh rehoboam in westworld season three
like introducing
a foul con and like falcon is a acronym
for
uh a fatal action
life uh colleen
and it's like a robotic falcon i
am you now then he has to fight him but
then he's just like okay let me tell you
the the ship of families will if you
replace all the planks
of [ __ ] family wilson can i get a loan
finally please
uh yeah um but i do think there was an
importance to taurus recording stuff i
mean you know i don't
i don't trust tourists right now taurus
is going to prove me wrong
like you got me you got me real sketchy
about torres like i
personally i'm just like i want to think
that taurus is a good boy i want to
think that taurus
is going to eventually become the falcon
um
like uh the tourist does in the comics
but like now you got me real sketchy
because like he was being so
sketchy it was he was recording sam and
he was just being so weird
so it's just like he he could have his
own little um
motives going on but we'll have to see
with torres really
um but yes another question
this isn't a serious question but i was
wondering
um when why do you think bucky got a
haircut
i think that is a very serious question
don't sell yourself short
uh there's a whole theoretic series
because mephisto that's why no
um i think no i think that was uh
or condition of his pardon right that
president i don't like that
no yeah i think he's trying to shut off
his winter soldier identity
you know and i think part of that is
cutting off that's those scary locks
seconds
exactly what do you do like what do most
people do when they get after a big
breakup
haircut they get they just cut their
hair just to be a different person you
know
so that's what bucky's doing he broke up
with hydro he's like i'm a new man
okay and uh but honestly i
i do think that he probably cut his hair
because a
uh his military roots i think that long
hair is just like just not a big thing
for him
and two like he's just he's
old-fashioned and like you know long
hair wasn't really
the go-to style i i want to say in his
time growing up so like he's just like
all right
you know this is my winter soldier do
like i they didn't really care about
hair care and hydra so like now that i'm
you know doing my own thing i'm just
going to keep it short like i used to do
and like you know
so yeah that's just how i see it but who
knows
high in tight yeah he's trying to
rediscover his humanity and uh
yeah people with long hair are not human
no
like i think that that long hair was
part of his mask it was part of like the
reason people couldn't look into his
eyes and now he's just trying to be
uh you know just more open to people and
more approachable i think that's part of
it
do you think rhodey is going to play a
bigger part in this show
because i mean he was in the
uh he was at the conference so maybe
he can play a bigger bigger role in the
show
i'm not sure what do you guys think yeah
he said i'll be in touch which could
mean a lot of things he's like i'll be
in touch three movies from now
um but i think i
uh i have a feeling that he might show
up once more in the show
um and like maybe at the end to kind of
set up where things are going next
but it wouldn't surprise me if we didn't
see rhodey be on this for
most of the show i think part of that
was to bring in to bring in donchi to a
familiar face so that some a familiar
avenger could ask him
why did you give up the shield and only
if like some other familiar face avenger
could uh be there to talk to him um
would we kind of accept an answer for
that
i think it's also uh isbc you know with
this series it's gonna address
race and i think uh there's gonna be
something there with with
rhodey getting sam's discomfort with
representing or fighting for his country
under the stars and stripes in this way
uh just being exploited as going on solo
missions that are that look like suicide
missions
i i think that's going to be important
oh yeah no for sure i think that like
roadies um the reason why marvel put
rhodey in that show specifically
and that you hit the deal right on the
head is because of the race issue and
like you know
um bucky's just straight up like why
didn't you take the mantle like that
would mean
a lot to a lot of people like us you
know
like we were really expecting you to do
this and so like please explain to me
why you didn't take this
and so um you know like and i i do
believe that roadie could show up at
least one more time but like i think
that this
is falcon and uh the winter soldiers
show
and they don't want any other avengers
to overshadow that
so um i mean we could see him pop up
again just to be like hey
you know uh here's some help or whatever
but like you know i think that they try
to
keep it as um you know focused on the
characters as possible
um but yeah tight like a good haircut
yeah
um let's take another question here do
you
think that captain america is dead
hmm that's a good one that's a really
good i mean
yeah i talked about that a bit in inside
marvel and uh also in the rogue theory
episode
everyone go watch that rogue theory
episode it's really good a lot of great
theories for where old cap could be
in uh in the mcu now um yeah i
uh it's hard to tell
because you could imagine when sam's
like oh i'm not gonna say if he's on the
moon or not that could just be a wink
and then later he'll go see this
quiet grave somewhere in brooklyn where
it's just old man cap's grave and he's
like i told i told them you were on the
moon jenae
[Laughter]
no no um but yeah i don't think we're
gonna see chris evans in this show
we may get a hint that like this old man
is working with nick fury up on a space
station
i think that'd be kind of crazy but
i don't think uh i it's hard i keep
going back and forth on this
what do you think mt i honestly think
cap
is not dead i feel like if
he is dead then they would have
concretely said it or
or been like yeah he's dead but they
kept saying gone
and i feel like something as big as
announcing
that cap is dead there would be a lot
more avengers there it wouldn't be just
roadie
um at that thing and like you know it
would be a bigger
deal i feel i mean this is just my
assumption anyway so i think that
cap um this is my head candy at this
point but i honestly think that cap is
just an old man
and that he came back and he gave him
the shield and then he just
didn't uh you know tell anybody that he
was around he was like it would just be
too complicated and people really
wouldn't understand
like i went to like back in time lived a
different timeline then came back it's
just like
let's just say that i'm just an old man
and no one really has to know where i
went
i'm just chilling and uh you know
exactly
uh eating pudding and all that stuff and
i don't know what people do but
probably a lot of pudding um i'm
assuming yeah so either
uh so i see we've kind of come at three
possible answers for where his old cap
either as mt said he's just in
retirement and enjoying like his life
but i would say he also already kind of
lived his life with uh peggy carter
so his you know the life that he wanted
is there so what's beyond that it's kind
of like the question that a lot of
widowers face of like well i'm still
around so what's next for me uh don't
retire reload my friend
go find another adventure out there we
all saw up we all cried when ellie said
uh
now go find an adventure of your own
it's like that's right just because
you're old doesn't mean your life has to
end go
find something out there for you uh a
new battle a new mission
um but the um but so there's either that
um or he uh is dead
and the reason sam kind of punted on
that question was a koi's thing saying
we're going to give you an answer on
what happened it's going to be a very
heartfelt
like sweet grave headstone conversation
uh so that's a second answer the third
answer is something
crazy and old man cap is based
or he went back to his home timeline the
answer is going to be in the multiverse
see the answer is going to be up on the
sword space station
or the peak i don't know if that is part
of the sword space station that's just
where that where all the scrolls are
um you know cap could be consulting in
the cree versus scroll war and he's like
i found cree sleeper cells over here
let's
deploy geronimo toronto
um so yeah i uh it's one of those three
i would say it's probably one of the
first two i don't want to go down that
rabbit hole yet
i my heart of heart hopes it's the third
option
every predept was the third option
honestly um we have time for
um a couple more questions i'm wondering
do you
think bucky's friend in brooklyn yuri
whose son he killed while
being brainwashed was an old friend of
his back in the 1940s
i like that idea um
you know the hard thing about it is the
that
yuri's son yuri's son who was killed on
that winter soldier mission seemed like
it was an accident like that guy wasn't
supposed to be there
he was supposed to go out drinking with
his friends uh winter soldiers didn't
expect to be seen by
a witness and he took out the witness as
was his
prerogative every time he was on a
mission so the fact that that guy would
just happen to be
an old uh friend's son as well kind of a
little too coincidental i would say
um also in the 1940s you know
america was at war with japan i don't
know if a us army soldier would be best
buds with like um a japanese person
at that time because back in those days
america was very very
suspicious we put japanese people who
were not
enemy combatants we put them in
internment camps yeah that was so i
don't know
if bucky a soldier fighting on the you
know in europe at the time would be like
oh i have this
this japanese friend who i'm gonna you
know not uh
who i'm not gonna act towards the way
the rest of my country's acting towards
japanese people at the time
yeah and like i think that like him
knowing them having that history would
probably
cheapen that the impact of what's going
on there because
you know bucky feels it's insanely
guilty for
killing this man's son and so he's sort
of like not replacing his son but like
spending time with this guy this guy's
father
um because he just feels super guilty
for about what he does
what he did so um i i feel like
um if they did know each other then like
this guy would know a lot about bucky's
past and like you know
um and would understand that like all
right this man is uh
um like does he know that he's an
avenger i mean i would hope so
but i don't know i mean i think you're
just friends i don't know well he cut
his hair he cut his hair so how could he
possibly know
he's an avenger who knows but like i i
definitely don't think that they know
each other uh that would be
yeah too much of a coincidence i think
if uh mr nakajima does know he's an
avenger i don't think
mr nakajima cares i think he's just like
oh here's this young man who for some
reason wants to spend time with me and
i'm grateful for that
uh and i'm gonna try to hook him up on
dates with people and it's just kind of
a sweet friendship yeah that's a great
way to get that reveal
yeah yeah he's a good wingman right he
would like to ask you out on a date
uh play some pinocchio um i think we
have time for maybe one more question
just wondering why do you think that um
bucky didn't answer sam's texts hmm
that's a good question didn't it remind
you of like uh civil war how
tony and cap like had this had these old
school flip phones and then they just
wouldn't respond to each other like
yeah sort of in a way yeah um i
i i think that there's
i think there's some degree of jealousy
there and i i don't want to say
um that there is but like i think that
there might be because um
like i just get that hint from the
trailer specifically
because bucky's just like oh there's a
big like you know legacy behind that
shield and like
i just think that he really oh i think
that at the very least he he cares
a lot about what that shield meant to
his best friend that is um
gone now and so he's just like i
feel like i'm the only one who knows i
was there from the beginning
so like if anyone should get that shield
it shouldn't be any of these young kids
out here it should be me
because i'm the oldest man on this
planet and like i just think this is
mine so like he's probably just like i
don't hate sam but i don't have to like
him
like i just you know i don't have to
talk to you but what do you think eric
oh i think it uh it harkens back to how
the fact that sam
is a veterans counselor i think the text
that and was sending to him is like look
if you ever want to talk
you know i have some training in this i
have some experience in this
you know you've been through so much if
you ever just need somebody to talk
through it with
and then bucky like he's resisting his
therapist right now he's like no
i don't i don't want to revisit this
stuff like he's trying to
block it out but then he's finding with
his nightmares he can't he can't
completely ignore it and move on he's
gotta work through it and that's
that's the nature of trauma you know you
have to you can't bury it because it's
gonna
crawl out of that grave at the worst
possible time and or while you sleep and
you're gonna get insomnia and that's
gonna hurt you another way so
i think that's what uh sam's been trying
to help with and uh
also there's kind of a love-hate
relationship between these two in
general you know
i really love that connection i didn't
even think about that that he was a a
counselor
in um in winter soldier um so that's
like he would 100
do that too that's so right you're so
true that's
i would yeah um well we are going to
wrap it up there uh obviously there's a
lot more questions we're so excited to
answer with uh
with the falcon and the winter soldier
going forward next week
uh and uh this show's such a fun start i
i love both these characters i love the
world that they're building in this show
and i can't wait to see how the show
kind of addresses some of these answers
or some of these questions and
and uh unfold its narrative but yeah be
sure to
watch our our breakdown uh once it comes
out or if it's already out
go watch inside marvel we we have a
fascinating conversation there
uh and uh yeah a way you can support
this channel we have
a new latest obsession shirt or latest
obsession number three
it's called anarchy assembled the design
of this shirt is
awesome it's inspired by the beautiful
closing credits of this show
and all the kind of creepy easter eggs
and conspiracies that are
on that on that graffiti wall so yeah we
have this new design
and uh it's falcon winter soldier
inspired it's a great way to support us
and when you get your hands on it it's a
collectible item so it's gonna be
numbered uh and we only have a certain
number of them so back in the blue
dungeon they'll go
and you can uh write in a custom shout
out that will appear in next week's
episode of inside marvel beneath
me and mt that's like an added thing you
can do if you choose to
um but yeah we want to thank all of you
for all your great questions we want to
thank our
listeners on stereo for sticking with us
we loved hearing from you guys
uh if you're watching this on on another
platform later you can get stereo and
listen
and react to us live in real time on the
stereo app stereo dot com slash new
rockstars
and we have um it seems like four shows
a week now where we're doing this it's a
great way that we've been able to
interact with you guys
um so it's it's really cool app and it's
free so
uh check that out um be sure to follow
mt
mastertainment uh on uh instagram and
twitter uh
the best instagram stories ever
i try to i just like to like post things
to make people laugh it's just like it's
fun it's good it works yeah me and kelly
will just be like oh mt has like a whole
bunch of stories now we're just like oh
my god
that's so freaking funny um so yeah
follow mt follow me at eavos uh follow
new rockstars at new rockstars
everywhere be sure to subscribe to the
channel if you aren't already and uh we
will see you guys next week
bye take it easy
[Music]
you